you had a very successful campaign you
were a very tough opponent for Hillary
Clinton and you said I think in one of
the earliest if not the first exchanges
between the two of you this may not be
good politics but I don't more or less I
don't care about your Damn emails the
peanut can people don't care about your
Damn emails
what happened is you did not bring it up
Trump then did bring it up brought it up
a lot hammered hammered her about it
relentlessly and it turned out there are
a lot of people voters in the country
that did care about those emails do you
wish now that you had made that more of
an issue no in your campaign no what I
said what I said that was that I think
it is imperative that we focus on the
real issues facing the American people
right why are we the only major country
on Earth that doesn't guarantee health
care or people paid family and medical
leave is it acceptable that we have so
much income and wealth inequality what
are we gonna do about climate change
what are we gonna do about immigration
reform or criminal justice reform there
are real issues that impact tens in tens
of millions of people those are the
issues that we need to discuss we need
to resolve right and but it must be
somewhat bitter to then watch after you
were out of the contest this other
person make it about everything else
really hammer this issue that you
thought was silly and get a lot of
traction on it
well Conan I think that has more to do
with the media frankly than it does with
Donald Trump all right what democracy is
about is placing the important issues on
the table and discussing them right you
may disagree with me so what that's
democracy what media loved was the fact
that Trump would say one absurd thing
after another ugly things about people
that we've never heard before from a
presidential candidate you know what
that was great TV that was great TV
CNN's ratings went way up I think the
American people have got to demand more
out of media the American people have
got to demand that media talk about the
issues that impact our lives can you get
by on ten bucks an hour what do you have
to raise the minimum wage why is it that
half of the elderly people in this
country are living on income so low that
they have nothing save for retirement
it's
etc we have got some real crises in his
country we got to talk about them you
had said
[Applause]
you had said I believe this I believe
this happened to you
you were being covered I don't I don't
want to say the wrong newspaper but it I
think it may have been the New York
Times but they were reading a story
about you they were covering your
campaign and while you were being driven
there was that you got a speeding ticket
your driver whoever was driving you was
driving too fast got a speeding ticket
and that the whole story became about
the speeding ticket rather than the
issues and to you that was kind of a
revelatory moment yeah well I mean
that's what it's about
if something stupid and personal happens
that becomes the story I mean turn on
network news tonight and watch it for
the next year see how much coverage
there is about climate change which is
threatening the existence of the entire
planet watch television for the cattle
the cows come home as we say in Vermont
and you'll hear very little discussion
about why we're the only major country
on Earth that to guarantee health care
to all people or why we pay the highest
prices in the world for prescription
drugs very little discussion about the
fact that the top one-tenth of 1% owns
as much wealth as the bottom 90% do you
think those are issues we should be
talking about yeah the American people
do network television and the reason for
that the reason for that pull right away
that is why I went to cable and I want
to make that clear but the reason for
that by the way it's not because not
because these guys are dummies there are
real conflicts of interest in terms of I
mean we don't talk about it who owns the
media well half a dozen major
conglomerates do they have vested
interests that are in conflict with the
public yeah you're damn right they do
you